just wear it but why you're a scientist
try to look like one it's really hard
and not all scientists wear lab coats
anyway how do you expect people to trust
you if you're not wearing a lab coat
well people can listen to what I'm
saying and they use their critical
thinking skills to work out whether or
not what I'm saying makes sense okay
fine it's Michelle from lab muffin
beauty science here chemistry PhD and
hyperpigmentation prone skin care nerd
today I'm going to be talking about how
to make your own DIY vitamin C serum
that will actually work if you like this
sort of video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel and click the
notification bellow so you don't miss
any videos what does vitamin C do I've
talked about vitamin C before in my
video on hyperpigmentation vitamin C is
a superstar anti-aging ingredient
vitamin C acts as an antioxidant which
means that it soaks up free radical
damage this can happen as a result of UV
exposure pollution or just natural aging
I have a video that talks a bit more
about how antioxidants work it also
phase hyperpigmentation such as the
brown spots that you might sometimes get
on your skin after acne as well as sun
spots but the big problem with vitamin C
is that a chance to be really unstable
this is especially the case with
l-ascorbic acid the main type of vitamin
C that's been shown to work in anti
aging products when L ascorbic acid is
in a water-based product it tends to
decompose really easily it turns into
yellow dehydroascorbic acid DHA or DHA
and other products really quickly at 25
degrees in ph 3.5 in amber glass which
is light protective about 50% is God in
a week DHA can convert back into
l-ascorbic acid on your skin and there's
no good evidence that it's bad for your
skin but there's not really much
evidence that it's good for your skin
either and it can turn it to other
products too you can stabilize
l-ascorbic acid by combining it with
some other ingredients a lot of products
take this approach they usually combine
it with vitamin E
through Erlich acid this is done in a
lot of popular vitamin C serum such as
the ones from skin suta khals Paula's
Choice timeless and drunk elephant but
if you want a DIY this combo then it's a
bit more of a hassle you'll have to buy
extra vitamin E and Furillo Cassatt plus
vitamin E doesn't dissolve well in water
that means that you'll have to use an
emulsifier so that will sit well with
your water-based vitamin C if you've
gone to this trouble then on top of that
you'll probably also want to use a
preservative so that you can keep the
serum for a longer time the price of all
these ingredients can add up quickly and
if you've ever done any DIY before
you'll probably know that you end up
accumulating lots of ingredients that
you never quite use up if you do want to
go down this more complicated route then
holy snails has a nice recipe which I'll
link to in the description you can also
stabilize l-ascorbic acid by changing
its structure so turning it into a
derivative some examples of these
derivatives of magnesium is Korbel
phosphate a Scoville tetra isoparm at 8
or 80 IP and tetra hexyl deckle
ascorbate or thta however these tend to
be quite expensive compared to plain
l-ascorbic acid plus it's not well
established how well these convert back
into l-ascorbic acid in your skin so
that's why I think a simple DIY vitamin
C serum that you remake every week or so
is a nice solution to some of these
problems I generally find DIY a bit of a
pain you have to buy all these
ingredients you have to mix them
together you have to play around with
the formula and there's all this washing
up that you generally have to do
afterwards but this DIY serum doesn't
have a lot of these drawbacks all the
ingredients are quite easy to get and
inexpensive it only takes about five
minutes to make it and once you get the
hang of it you also have a better idea
of how fresh it is compared to a
store-bought product you don't have to
think about how long it's been sitting
on the shelf
how long the delivery is whether it's
gone through any massive temperature
fluctuations while it's sitting in water
you can also easily adjust the amount of
vitamin C in your serum you can just add
a bit more or a bit less l-ascorbic acid
if you want more effectiveness or less
irritation it's also cheap enough that I
can use it on other parts of my body
without feeling bad about using an
expensive product to make a vitamin C
serum which matches what's been used in
studies that have found positive effects
you want something that's generally
between five and 20 percent at a pH of
about 3.5 so here's what you need for
this DIY vitamin C serum first you need
l-ascorbic acid powder as a dry solid
l-ascorbic acid is reasonably stable and
cheap you can find this at most
supplement stores or you can order it
off I heard like I did there are also
lots of options on Amazon you also want
some distilled or deionized water metal
eyes in your water can speed up how
quickly l-ascorbic acid decomposes you
can also use tap water and just make
sure you remake your serum more
frequently you'll also need some baking
soda the pH of l-ascorbic acid by itself
in water is going to be a bit too low
it's a bit too acidic which means that
it will cause unnecessary irritation
baking soda is alkaline which is the
opposite of this and so we can use it to
adjust the pH back up closer to skin pH
you'll also need some pH strips it
doesn't need to be really really precise
so any indicator stress should work I
generally prefer foursquare indicator
strips so don't have to second-guess my
color matching abilities you'll also
want a quarter teaspoon measuring spoon
a quarter teaspoon
translates to about one and a half grams
of ascorbic acid but it does depend on
your particular powder ideally if you
weigh it out it's a bit more accurate
but because there's so much leeway in
the percentage of vitamin C that we can
use in this serum then it isn't a
massive issue for this specific recipe
of course you'll also need a suitable
container to store your vitamin C serum
you want an airtight ish clean container
it doesn't have to be truly airtight
because you'll be remaking this quite
frequently if you have an old container
you can clean and reuse that you can
also use some aluminium foil to protect
your vitamin C serum from light so
here's how you make your DIY serum your
first step is to work out your recipe
start by working out how much serum you
can fit into your container in
milliliters you should be able to find
this out from the place you bought the
bottle foam or from the packaging if
it's a reused container if you can't
work it out you can use the teaspoon and
measure how many teaspoons you can fit
into your container next you need to
calculate how much l ascorbic acid you
need you take the percentage you want to
by a hundred then multiply it by the
volume of the container and that will
give you the mass of l-ascorbic acid you
need in grants for example if I'm making
20 mils of a 10% l-ascorbic acid I'm
going to need two grams next you need to
clean your container
I recommend washing it out thoroughly
with soap and water then rinsing it with
alcohol a few times then rinsing it with
distilled water and letting it dry it
doesn't have to be completely sterile
because again we're going to be remaking
this quite frequently plus it's a quite
a low pH which micros will have a hard
time surviving in then you put your
l-ascorbic acid into your container
add about half of the distilled water
that you're going to use into the
container and shake it until it
dissolves we're only using half of the
water at this stage because it's a lot
easier to shake a container that's not
completely full then you add the rest of
the water and turn it upside down a few
times to make sure it's thoroughly mixed
next we need to adjust the pH put a drop
of the serum on to your pH strip and
look at what the pH is
then add a tiny bit of baking soda
recheck the pH and keep doing this until
you get it through somewhere between
three and four
finally you can wrap your container up
in foil to protect her from light this
is the easiest and cheapest way of
protecting something from light and so
this will slow down how quickly your
vitamin C serum decomposes with light
protection I found that this DIY serum
lasts about one week before going a
little bit yellow and then two weeks
before it goes really yellow the pH is
low enough that microbial growth
shouldn't be a big issue and you're not
keeping up for very long once you're
used to this process
it probably takes less than five minutes
to remake so even someone who's pretty
lazy like me can remake up quite
frequently I hope you enjoyed this video
and found it useful if you do click the
like button and subscribe to my channel
you can also follow me on Instagram at
lab life and beauty science and check
out my blog for more nerdy Beauty
science see you next time are you a
scientist or a science isn't I am so
sweaty